good morning everyone
lower drug cost now good morning thank
you all for being here as we know for
years seniors and families across
America have struggled under the
skyrocketing cost of prescription drugs
drugs they need to stay healthy but also
the cost of drugs threatening their
financial health and well-being as well
I've always said in our meetings that
when you travel the country the issue of
the cost of prescription drug is one
subject that can make grown men cry just
cry about not being able to deal with
those cost what it means to again to the
health and well-being of their families
because of cost the burden of out of out
of control prescription comes an issue
that touches every family in America
that was self evident in the election of
2018 it's still a big issue as we go
forward we don't want a political issue
at the polls we want a solution in the
Congress and we want it now on health
Committees of jurisdiction under our
outstanding chairman of Energy and
Commerce chairman Frank pallone mr. Neal
Ritchie Neal chair of the Ways and Means
Committee and chairman Bobby Scott I
want to thank them for their leadership
and the hard work of their staffs their
stats to